keep a straight face
what is hard to do so thank you to
Patrick this is where I cannot say it
enough operations - we are in this
together this situations and again take
the heat of some of the warnings that
they put out the last several loans you
can put on our public safety services so
be aware and again my deepest
appreciation goes on to the mayor
locally and all the public in all the
city work is quite frankly you are
coming to dare to protect not only the
city's up open but also the residents
that we have also defensive Institute's
thank you
good afternoon Darren white from fire
department fire chief in response to
Pacific Gas and electrics announcement
that more than likely to activate a
public safety power shutdown I'm happy
to announce that the ultimate fire
department all city departments multiple
jurisdictions multiple agencies all
collaboratively collaborative and are
prepared merchandise in addition as we
know the National Weather Service has
issued red flag warnings conditions
effective tomorrow through Thursday so
with that we've taken some very
proactive steps to ensuring that we're
prepared for any eventuality some of
those steps include we're implementing
roving patrols effective tomorrow
morning through the end of the event
that will be in addition to the normal
people that would normally perform with
our existing staff we are up staffing
we're gonna rely in part on a lot of
mutual aid assistance in a way of almost
20-plus different units we're gonna
provide response to us upon request if
need be for any event that may occur
we've also made a request through the
California Office of Emergency Services
for pre-positioned units that consists
of usually several apparatus that are
able to come and deploy immediately in
the event you have a dynamic situation
as requiring emergency immediate
response for an emergency bobland nature
and origins additionally we've secured
an hour an ongoing discussions right now
with our Transport Agency is about
increasing units that can actually work
for both emergency and non-emergency
transport purposes more that is evolving
as
moving into tomorrow for that that
request was one thing I would like to
remind everybody about is for those of
you who live in the hills where we know
there is challenges with access and
egress for first responders and other
members of the community we asked you to
remember to park officers in your
driveways we also ask that everyone as a
reminder sign up for AC alerts and
because we've seen timely updates and
notifications WWE well I can tell you
right now initially Pacific Gas and
Electric identified certain areas that
are predominantly located in the hill
areas of our community and so I don't
believe a lot of that area extends down
to our critical infrastructure whether
it be our hospitals whether it be some
of the main transportation arteries
whether it be the Port of Oakland
whether it's maritime or aviation
division I don't think that's a concern
at this point however as most people are
aware or should remember a fast-moving
wildfire may not stay just centrally
located in the hill areas it could
expand throughout the other areas of the
city and so with that we're also on
heightened alert and concerned that PG&E
may make a decision ultimately to expand
the footprint of that public safety
shutdown or power shutdown rather yes
sir yes
[Music]
if the power goes down sorry John Sasaki
communications director an Oakland
Unified School District I've got a list
of schools that we have potentially
affected by what is going on here there
are total of 12 schools that we're
talking about
they are Grass Valley Elementary Howard
Elementary Parker elementary Montclair
elementary Sequoia elementary and
Fruitvale M Elementary then there's
Elmhurst United middle school Bret Hart
middle school Skyline High School Rudd's
Dale High School Sojourner Truth and Bay
Tech Charter Sojourner Truth Bay Tech
Charter and ruts Dale are all in the
same campus so if indeed we have power
outages to those schools those schools
will not be in session tomorrow it is
important to note that we have 71 other
schools that will be in session tomorrow
unless something dramatically changes
but based on what we know now those
twelve schools will be affected tomorrow
if indeed PG calls this power shut down
it is a matter of making sure that
everybody is safe is not a matter of
making sure that if there is an
emergency that follows a power outage we
can get everybody out if need be in a
very quickly in quick orden orderly
fashion so it's just a matter of making
sure that everybody is where they need
to be with regard to being as safe as
possible in the case of not having power
in our schools or frankly our schools
just can't function and do all the
things that they need to do with regard
to teaching and learning and all the
other support that they provide our
students on our staff
in case of a power outage so those 12
schools if indeed PG&E calls a power
shutdown could be affected tomorrow and
we will in the end if we find that out
that this power shut off is happening we
will be calling each individual school
the entire school community all the
staff all our students and their
families and letting them know that
there will be no school tomorrow
our schools just can't function and do
all the things they need to do with
regard to teaching and learning and all
the other support that they provide our
students our staff in case of a power
outage
so those twelve schools if indeed Peking
calls a power shutdown could be
effective tomorrow we will and if we
find that out that this power shut off
is happening we will be calling each
individual school the entire school
community of all the staff our students
and their families we're hoping that
teaching is able to let us know earlier
rather than later or hoping at least by
8:00 p.m. tonight we can send out calls
to those schools I would love to do it
earlier because we know that our
families are are put in a tough position
a lot of problems with with child care a
lot of them have to work so they can't
easily take time off if their kids have
to be at home so we have to give them as
much leeway as possible as much lead
time as possible so that they can make
also have plans talk to you again
the schools are Grass Valley
Howard Parker Montclair Sequoia
Fruitvale Elmhurst United Bret Hart
Schoen high school
Rosedale high Sojourner Truth and Bay
Tech Charter will it all go out it
doesn't happen if if you as a parent or
a family member or a staff member do not
receive a call you can assume that your
school is functioning tomorrow we will
be called in every single school that is
effective within me that's what happens
with that NBC Bay Area news this is a
question her you guys are getting up for
hours heads up time all I would say is I
would like to have as much lead time I
think everybody else here would like to
have as much free time as possible so
we're hoping that we get we find out
earlier rather than later and if people
do show up to those schools to tomorrow
will there be someone there to chose to
send them away if if we do have closures
there will be staff on-site to let
everybody know that unfortunately you
can't have students on school
are you there are gonna be
accommodations at other sites for
parents who have to work or we're still
trying to determine exactly how we can
handle this and this is going to affect
potentially if all 12 those schools are
affected it could potentially affect
about 5,000 students so we're gonna have
to try to find other ways to do it but
but that's a lot of students and so it
especially on such short notice it may
not be possible to find accommodations
for all of them and then the other
question is a lot of other districts are
planning to be open even if they try
trying to figure out exactly what what
what trying to figure out exactly what
on our campus is still function without
power we do have some emergency
generators about that but I don't know
according to Pacific Gas & Electric they
anticipated to take up to five days to
restore power we always advise the
community to prepare to be without
resources or assistance for at least 72
hours so in this particular case I would
say in the back end of what PG&E is
recommended but there's a possibility
they could restore power sooner and I
believe that it really depends on how
quickly they can get out and inspect
lines and ensure that they can re
energized those lines one city energize
the base videos for the chief or anyone
else who knows from what you said
earlier it sounds like the initial
outage area most likely with the women
through the hills sitting there well yes
based on the initial information we
received it's predominantly located in
our threat zone areas which are large
seen primarily yes
if people want to see whether or not
their actual address is impacted there
is a tool on PG news website PG e.com or
you can enter your own address now we've
heard that there have been some issues
with that site staying up because as you
might imagine it's been flooded we're
trying to place as much information as
possible from PG news site on the City
of Oakland site so that there is another
place for people to drill to get
critical information and we have been
also advised that the map that shows the
area is actually a little larger than
the actual address is impacted so there
is not a perfect synchrony synchronising
of those those things but again the
five-day scenario is only if equipment
is actually blown down during these high
winds and it needs to be prepared be
prepared and it is our hope that that
does not happen five days without the
electricity it's pretty unacceptable
for our community and we certainly will
expect PG&E to do everything within its
power to assure that we don't see those
kinds of
mayors are there any concerns about
looting about people using this as an
opportunity to target certain
neighborhoods certain stores we are
prepared to keep this city safe as the
chief said every single officer has had
his or her time off canceled we are
fully staffed to keep this city running
well and I can say from personal
experiences of living my entire life in
Oakland that times like this are often
when our communities showed their best
signs when people come together we
certainly have seen messages going out
on the next-door network really showing
concern and care for neighbors and we
expect Oakland ders to live up to these
values of taking care of each other of
being compassionate of thinking of
others and keeping everyone safe mayor
has the city received all the
information from PG&E that it needs to
and you know that this is a first this
is the first time that we received
notification of a plant power outage I
will say that it is good to have some
warning rather than no warning which can
often happen in a natural disaster again
we expect PG&E to do everything to
minimize impact to residents but the
idea of five days without electricity is
devastating and we fully expect that to
be a worst-case scenario this is our
first time going through this we hope
that some power outage does not happen
at all but this is an opportunity for us
all to prepare for us all to ask the
tough questions to PG&E as well as other
agencies that are responsible for
emergency preparedness and response you
spend now with ABC 7 News can you
explain to us the urgency of this you
said each as lucy's that's information
today I mean is well yesterday we you in
contact with them previously in what
happened white why is this happening now
you know we have received information
from PG&E that planned power outages are
part of their strategy to avoid the
devastating wildfires that we've seen
over these last year's paradise' the
camp
and and so we obviously value human life
and we will assume that this is
necessary to avoid devastating fires and
to preserve life we respect that we
honor that and we will abide by this
this is an evolving world where these
extreme weather conditions that we see
from climate change are happening and we
have got to adjust you see behind me
some of the best professionals in this
business and so I appreciate all the
work that they're doing with this short
notice
emergency and the continued work that we
are always doing to be ready to respond
as well as bounce back from these types
of natural disasters Oakland has had to
do it in the past and we will do it
again are you hoping it doesn't happen
there's no power at it again I this is
the type of interruption to life that
should not happen
we should have systems that
don't require a power outage
particularly provided the idea that PG&E
has got to maintain its infrastructure
in a way that's safe that takes into
account the extreme weather conditions
that we're seeing these high wind
incidences that is something that I will
continue to push for because this type
of interruption is not acceptable we are
going to do it because we agree that is
in the interest of the safety of people
but we have got to do better
infrastructure for the long term this is
probably a very large issue not just the
funding I know living in Berkeley that's
an issue obviously is who pays for it
and benefited would that be an ideal so
let me be clear right now fire safety is
not a criteria for utility funded under
grounding I believe it should be and I
think that it's something that residents
in Oakland should think about advocating
for as we move forward into the
legislative season because right now
that is not a criteria it should be
hey all right let me knew last question
okay thank you you're welcome
for John so a the 5,000 garments of the
kids already receive at least one
Advisory's so basically what the clerk
is waiting for a confirmation for them
right we we let the entire district know
that this was going on
last night we sent a message to the
entire district but we will be informing
this specific schools later today I also
wanted to point out someone was asking
about whether this was really primarily
the hilt with regard to schools it's not
we have a couple of schools that are
affected in our in the Hills common high
school Montclair elementary but there
are a lot of schools in the flatlands
Parker elementary Elmer's United and one
of the interesting things about those
two schools is they are on either side
of the castle not high school and
council one's not affected at least
according to this list so far so it is
an interesting kind of haphazard looking
manner that affects some schools that
you might think are being affected like
in the Hills and others are not affected
but are some schools affected in the
others aren't so deep maybe I would
comment on this better but my
understanding is it is it's because the
schools are played by a power lines at
the turning off the power of speed lines
are there just aside why they're talking
about depending on and those go directly
to these schools in those neighborhoods
deputy chief Nick Looby who's gotten
more for me
nicholae operational c4c Myron's we
answered a question about how it's
selected PG&E has given us a map upward
projected power Public Safety car shut
down is it is a not a straight line it
is tied into how the grid system the
electrical grid system is set up and
where they can isolate circuits is what
they've explained to us and how the
wiring is configured on their
infrastructure so that is that is what
dictates where the PSPs happens and also
that plays into where the weather event
is taking place so as it stands now as
John Sasaki said they're showing us what
the worst case scenario is and that's
where the schools are being allocated
for that maybe closed
PG&E has said that they are continuing
to work to try and minimize impacts by
population so where they have the most
densely populated areas are the most
number of households that are served by
that particular power station they are
trying their best to minimize impacts
they also if there is an outage there
they will try their best to restore
power in a way that benefits the most
people the fast
we appreciate that do you feel like the
city is at the mercy of PG&E I mean
what's your message to PG&E after all
these are deciding where the power
outage is going to take place if it does
happen in fact I mean it's affecting so
many of your residents in the city I
will continue to urge PG&E to put the
people before their shareholders that
this needs to be about public safety not
about cost savings again that is the
message they have given us but we should
continue to hold them to that that they
are protecting their infrastructure they
are updating it they are maintaining it
properly so that this type of
unacceptable interrupt to people's lives
does not have to happen now that said we
have to all of us have recognized how
important it is to invest in our
infrastructure to invest in maintenance
and to constantly be adjusting to the
realities of climate change and extreme
weather conditions that we are seeing
more and more
I do hope that we continue to support
PG&E
in taking safety measures that will
avoid these types of power outages in
the future I do hope that we prioritize
fire safety as a criteria for utility
funded under grounding but in the
meantime we have to take this very
seriously and I do feel that the
direction to shut down power to avoid
the type of devastating loss of life
that we have seen through these
wildfires is something that absolutely
is justified thanks folks we're gonna
wrap up I just wanted to make one final
comment that all city facilities parks
recreation centers libraries are
currently open with the exception of
Joaquin Miller Park which by city
ordinance is closed on red flag day so
while Kim Miller Park is closed you may
want to check with these big regional
parks about other Ridgeline parks status
this is an evolving situation obviously
we're going to have more information
coming and as we if we lose power and
need to close city facilities we would
keep the lists up on our website
I tend to keep you posted about about
the involving closed resistors actually
but that will keep you posted
stay tuned on Oakland CA thanks